this is a production of cornell
university
okay uh good afternoon
thanks dear for your introduction
before i get started i would like to say
a few words
for this seminar
that is i'll be given it
as a
extension seminar
so
my extension program
targets
at two groups of audience
the apple industry and the general
public
especially
the master gardener volunteers
so today
i will be treating you guys as part of
these two groups for next hour
so with that said
uh here's my
outline of my talk today
i will be basically addressing two
questions
the first is what is genomics
i'll be
beginning with a few key concepts in
genomics
and then
talk about
major accomplishments in genomics
the second question is why genomics is a
vital solution for challenges
in fruit and vegetable production
so this is a focus on my talk today
i'll be mentioning
briefly the challenges we're facing
and then describe the
solutions of genomic solution for these
challenges
i'll be using cabbage black rod
resistance
and apple
fruit quality as example
so before i get started okay the first
question
is about what is genomics
so now to answer the question
let's look at this picture first okay
this one is a really a touching story
is the slide itself is adopted
from
a from the fly
of a french documentary made a couple
years ago
the guerrilla
named digit
uh
lived with the family
peer and anionic for four years
the the grid has really become a
member of the family
but in the end
the griller
has to
leave
back to where she really belongs
because the fully grown uh gorilla is
really different from humans
now from the point of genetics
the difference is caused by the genome
okay
so in other words we can say that it is
the genome
that makes this family must be quick
enough
so
but please do not
uh think genome is a bad thing
uh
actually it is also the genome that
make us who we are
why we have such a diverse world
for the same reason
the apple fruits
can be always distinguishable from other
fruits such as pear
and
peach
so so you may think it's easy to
understand the difference
between the species are caused by
by the genome
so what about the difference
within a same genome well that would
also caused by the genome as well
the answer is yes
so for example
um
these are the four types of vegetables
okay
but they belong to the same species
called brassica wrapper
if you
look at how they differ from each other
but if you look at their genome sequence
probably more than 99 percent
they are the same
but the one percent difference is enough
for what you see here
so this this says
that the genome not only
determines the difference
between
the species
but also determine the difference within
the same same species
a little variation in the genome that
can make a huge difference
in their appearance
okay talk about the genome what is
genomic value
okay in a scientific term
genome is a total collection of dna or
genes
in a reproductive cell
such as sperm egg pollen
that contains
all of the genetic genetic information
needed
to build a organism
so a genome is really
like a blueprint
for building a magnificent building
such as empire building with all
families
now
the dna of genome
contains a lot of meaning meaningful
bases
so if you print the genome
there will be a hugely sick book
so in the upper genome
there are
about
750
million bases
so the apple genome book
would have
750 million
letters
assuming we can print 3000 letters per
page
that would
count for
a quarter million pages
now
in the genome of a
napa cabbage
the the genome book will be a little bit
thinner
with
284 million letters but it still take
about
95
uh thousand pages to print it all out
so in the living cells
the genome
dna
is naturally
divided into a limited number of units
and organized into a structure called
chromosomes as shown in this picture
so the apple genome have 17 chromosomes
if we're using the concept of book
so the apple genome book would have 17
chapters
now similarly for the
prosecutor napa which is a rubber
cabbage
they have 10
10 chromosomes so the brassica rubber
cabbage genome book would have 10
chapters
now gene is another important concept in
genomics i think
you have heard about it
so genes are the basic functional unit
of genome
and
genes carry
important genetic information
so genes
are located at the various locations
along this chromosome
so a single genome can be a home
for genes of thousands
the textbook the text box here should
actually shoot a dna sequence for a gene
actually this is the gene
uh responsible for controlling apple
fluid acidity we identified recently
so the first three-letter
atg serves as a like a start button
for the gene gets translated
and the last three letters
serves for the stop button
for
translation termination
the mother letter somehow
changed the basis
in the middle of the red g g 1455 we
call it
are two a1455 in some of the above
varieties
that makes those levels
are testless because the lcd is too low
so now with the introduction to genome
now let's talk about what is genomics
okay genome in short word is a study of
genome
is mainly
investigating the structure and function
of the genome or whole genome
okay depending on the area of a vocals
there are structural genomics
functional genomics comparative genomics
and synthetic genomics and many others
so genomics is a new and dominating
discipline in genetics it's part of
genetics
much has been accomplished in fruit and
vegetable genomics
this slide shows about
about 17 fruits and vegetables
which genome has been sequenced
including
apple and grape
and
oranges and tomato i want to mention
that
sequencing of the tomato genome is
primarily primarily laid
by
jim giuliani here at
bdi
the development of talents based
biotechnology
is another
major accomplishment
in genomics
so talents stand for the world a little
bit over here
stand for transcription activated like
effects nucleus
talents based biotechnology is a major
breakthrough
in biotech in biotechnology
that come out
from the genomic studies
the major property of tannin
is to make a cut
in the genome
at a specific location
so
talent is extremely useful
and the worst was a hard tool for genome
editing because of that property
another the major advantage of
talent-based biotechnology is that
talents improved vegetables and fruits
are very comparable
with
those that are developed
by
conventional breeding
because there's no foreign mold i'll
come back to all this a little bit later
too
so the the bottom drawing shows a talent
that
cut
a
target site in the genome
okay so much for the for the
introduction of genome and genomics so
now let's
address the second question
why
is genomics a vital solution for
challenges in fruit and vegetable
production
it's always challenging in
production frozen vegetables
nowadays so in addition to
the labor the rising labor cost and the
material cost
profitability and pest control
are the major challenges
to
address
the profitability challenges
optimizing cropping system and practice
for high
yield and quality
are commonly used
to
control the damaging disease and pests
and insects
the chemical sprays are used most
frequently
are there any other means
that are
more
cost effective
what about
develop developing
superior varieties
of fruits
or vegetables
that are naturally
of
high yield and quality
and resistance
to multiple diseases and insects
from any standard
this is likely the base approach
this is why
genomics
can provide a wider tool wider solution
for the challenges we are facing in
fruit and vegetable production
there are two ways genomes can
provide solutions for developing such
superior varieties
the first will be using biotechnology
so given the controversy controversy
of existing biotechnology
the talent specific technology
really holds the promise
i can see
a lot of
lot along
a way
we will go
breathing by design
the second
would be help
conventional breeding
by
market system breeding or genomic
selection
so i will now show you with examples
first example is
improvements of black rod resistance in
brassica around brussels on the racy
black rod is probably the most damaging
disease in christopher's worldwide
and the causal agent
is bacterium
uh the somalis competitors competitors
black rod
is especially damaging to
brassica on a racy
vegetables
such as cabbage
so the photo
on the lower left side
shows
the black road damage to cabbages in the
field and the photo on the lower right
side shows
the lateral damage
inside a cabbage
i got this photo from
from
from grief
sound for his help
in addition to cabbage
there are several common vegetables
that are also brassica on the races
including broccoli
and cauliflower
and brussels sprouts
and several others shown here
so all of these particular anorexic
vegetables have problems of
a black
viral
disease problem
so
what makes black rod
a particular problem for brassica owner
racing
there are at least uh
three factors that are contributing to
this this situation the first is the
the source of black road resistance in
brassica on a race is very rare
there are only about two assessions
report of resistance
as shown as shown here
the second
the resistance is very very specific
and rest dependent
the third factor is the resistance can
only be
partially bred into new cultivars
so because of these
limitations breeding for high
resistance
high black road resistance
has made with little success
to help with
this long struggle for high
level resistance
two
talents based
uh approach are envisioned
the first is to
identify the resistant genes from
brassica relatives
and then
transfer them into a blaster on a racing
so the second
is to directly
modify the
susceptibility genes
within brassica analysis to convert that
into
resistant genes
so for the first approach we need we
need to know
what the resistance are there in the
prosecutor relatives
why the resistance in protocol relatives
cannot be bred
into brassica on the racing
now here shows strong resistance
existing in several
brassica species including brassica rapa
brassica [ __ ] brassica
but
the resistance in these relatives
cannot be
easily bred into prosecutor analysis
to explain that let's look at the
relationships
between the brassica species
there are
six major brassica species
including three
deployed and three tetraploid
the three
the three deploys
are
brassica wrapper
of 18
of 10 chromosomes
and prostagland [ __ ] of beijing
of eight chromosomes and brassica
on the resin
obsidian of nine chromosomes
so there are
three
tetaplus
species are thought to be derived
from the natural hybridization
between the diploid species followed by
chromosome doubling
um
the
genome of lava cabbage which is we call
the plaster
lava has been completely sequenced and
the pascal on earth on the left
certainly is a topic of this example
now if you make a course
between brussels analysis with any of
these species with resistance
the hybrid will be not viable not viable
because the imbalance of chromosome
numbers
so this explains
why the resistance in other vascular
species cannot be
moved
into practical analysis by conventional
breeding
therefore
tenants-based
biotechnology is an ideal choice for
moving the brassica
native resistant gene into vascular
analysis
the
second approach is more exciting because
we don't need to involve any other
personal species
we simply need to identify the
susceptibility genes
this approach
has been
recently demonstrated successfully in
rice
i'll show you in next slides
now the first row
shows a part of a gene
in a
rice cartival
that is
susceptible to
bacterial blood disease
which is a most described disease in
rice
one of them
now the rest of the rose basically is
the mutations
that are induced by talents
okay those the dash
stand for the dna that were missing that
are deleted by the
by the
talents and the red letters in the red
are the dna bases added
by their
talents
now here's a comparison
of the difference in addition name
between the non-modified control
and the tenant's modified rise line
so it's clear
that
the susceptibility gene
has been converted into
this resistant genes
as i said the
talents modified last line contains
no foreign dna
so these right lines are really
comparable
with conventional bread
any rice varieties
so with talent-based approach
uh high black road resistance in
brussels on a racy
will be available so
so this is so much for the first example
now i'm going to
talk about the second example
which is the improvement of fluid
quality based on a flow acidity
i will show you how much assisted
breeding
has been done or can be done to improve
fruit of quality
there's two major reasons to
begin with
apple fruit acidity
the first reason is that
fruit acidity
largely determines fruit taste and
flavor
so fruit acidity is one of the major
components that affect fruits
quality
so other components includes crispr
crispness firmness juiciness size
syllable content storability and texture
and the second reason
probably the major reason the apple
breeders led through the city the number
one priority training
for breeding and for genetic studies
i'll come back to this point
why appropriated ready
through the float acidity the number one
priority trade
apple varies
widely in
in the first city
levels based on our own measurement full
ph varies from 2.8
to 4.5
and
to triple acidity the ta
varies from 0.07
to 0.187
the
accessible range for a desired apple
variety
is ph
3.1 to 3.8
or ta 0.3 to one percent
above flows
with through the city levels beyond this
range
are either too high
or too low
in a city
in epigenetics it's known that
acidity levels is primarily controlled
by the gene we called ma as i mentioned
earlier
there are two
alleles or versions of this gene
and one for high
acid one for low acid
the high acid allele is dominant over
the lowest value
so there are three possible genotypes in
apple
homey likes high acid genotype
and heterolytic high acid genotype
and
home like homologous low acid genotype
because apple receives one allele
from the seed parent another layer from
the pollen
in a survey
79 percent of the name level varieties
are
heterozygous genotype
and fourteen percent homologous highest
unit of and seven percent homozygous
lowest units
so this is high as two high acetylene
type supposed to produce fruits over
high acid and the low acetylene type
produces lowest difference
when an apple has a low acid in your
type the fruit tastes very flat
no flavor
so in breeding programs those seasonings
will be useless no commercial value near
the certain way as quickly as possible
since
the high
the heterozygote high acetylene type is
dominant
in the named above varieties
the most brilliant population is derived
from two
genotypes that are both
heterozygous high acid
as shown here
so the protein is of this kind of
crosses
segregates like one quarter of the union
of low acid genotype
so although this
breeder knows that okay growing in this
genus has useless is wasting time money
but they cannot
throw them away with confidence
that's why the rate for the city is
number one priority trade
if someone can help them doing this one
they'll be great so
that's why we wanted to
identify the fruit of staging
so through extensive efforts we were
able to
reveal the identity of genome genema
as i mentioned
earlier
the imagine
has
1707
dna bases
and encoding a magic acid transport
protein
of 568 amino acids
the arrow
stands for the radiant direction of the
gene okay
the upper two rows
shows the dna bases
and their corresponding positions
with
orbs with omission of the majority okay
now the lower two rows shows the
corresponding
amino acid residues and the
corresponding position
we found that a single living
a single base mutation
from
g1455
to
a1455
in the gene ma is responsible for low
acid fruit
as i mentioned earlier
the reason is that the mutation
caused a premature
stop button
in the imaging
as shown here
this is a mutation then they call this
stop button here so then they cut off
the rest of the
amino acids which is 84 of them
so presumably these
cause the imagine malfunction
so with the finding of this gene we want
to use it in our brain
now we developed a marker called caps
1455
to
specifically type in the mutation site
and the location
now this gel shows
a a
example of analysis of the marker caps
1455
in a diverse set of apple varieties and
selections
each of the lanes
stand for apple variety or a selection
the top ends
stand for high acid allele
the lower band stands for low acid
allele
the single tall bands
in this lens
are for homozygous high acid in red
and the single lower bands
in the lens
stand for homozygous low acid genotype
and those with two bands
are stand a stand for heterolites
high acid genotype
so
those in red and in yellow are expected
to produce fruit of high acid and those
in white are expected to produce fruit
of low acid
here is a ph data for those varieties
and selections
this is is exactly what we expected
for example
in the three wire lanes
which is a homologous lowest genotype
the ph measured from 4.3 to 4.5
very high ph
just in low acid
so this indicating that
markov caps protein
the caps 1455 is a versatile marker
for marker associated breeding
how to apply this marker in above
reading
so the first will be
marker
marker
sydney marcus is the selection of
signings
so in collaborative collaboration with
our breeder dr susan brown
we test this marker
in her in one of her large above
breeding population
again
each lane stands for siemens so this
gear picture was just showing part of
the results
now the
the lane the lane with a single bat
that indicated with a
red arrow
are for homologous high acid genotype
and
those with the two bands
indicated with a yellow arrow
are
heterozygous high acid genotype
and those
with a single lower band
are homozygous lower the tenderness
so
just based on we have 96
unions shown here so we have about 23
percent with low estimate
it's very close to 25
as we
expected
so those feelings
seriously can be thrown away
i have suggested also but she hasn't
so the
second
approach
the second application is the market
system
planning for new crosses
now the idea is to maximize
the heterozygous high acid genotype in
the protein while minimize
the
portion of law of homolytic low estrogen
attack
so
the basic cross
will be made between a homolog lowest
genotype and a
homologous high-efficiency
location here with dark green
because proteins of this crosses a
hundred percent
heterogeneous highest genetic
so the cross is between
two
heterozygous highest genotype or between
a heterozygous hydrogen up with a
homologous hydrogen but also
acceptable
and the cross is made between a
homologue laws genotype with
a uh
headed like a high achieving that can be
done
but
half of that fifty percent of the scenes
will be
segregated for low estrogen type
so closest to a void are those between
two
homologue low estrogen type and two homo
high acid nutrients
okay in summary so genome is the total
collection of dna or genes in
reproductive cells
the genome genomics is a study of the
structural function of the whole genome
our talent represents one of the major
breakthroughs in genome editing
and in
precise and clean genetic engineering
and genomics provides vital solutions
for challenges that cannot be
effectively addressed
through conventional breeding
genomics helps increase breeding
efficiency especially in tree fruits
of a long juvenile phase
i want to thank
dr suleiman
leonard chen and general father for
their help in uh
florida city project i also would like
to thank debbie
and laurie for help in my extension
program
yambae is my grad student and laura is a
technician in the lab
so i would like to stop here
thank you for our attention and ready
for any questions
this is a very nice question uh
that's the question i ask myself all the
time
um
actually i didn't show uh here
when we uh
try to identify the gnma
we
genotyped many
many
apple signalings
in the population
so if you look at
their uh distribution
it's clearly the two peaks
that's the breaking points around 3.8 in
ph
and the ta is around
0.3
so so that's why we put one category as
a low
acid
another category with a high acid
now
you're absolutely right so there's a
continuous variation within either of
the categories
so i think this
is the next phase of our goal to find
out what exactly what exactly causing
that
but the imagine the major function of
the imaging is to
make that curve
okay for the higher s group and for low
ethical now to find tony need
certainness there's other facts involved
that's true that's
that's the things we are pursuing
very vigorously when i have that i'll
let you know
yes uh
well i
i don't mean
to discount
the rules of copying system and
and the orchard or the field management
no this is not my point
uh i i realize these very important uh
efforts need to be done need to be in
place to
uh manage
uh the field or the orchard
now the point that i try to make is
if we have a resistant variety that will
be really helpful
and that's not all certainly not all i
agree with that thank you
i think this will be helpful i i don't
know how what
what really the process will be in the
regulation
but i would say that
based on the fact
okay um
there's no foreign dna being involved
in those talents
modified lines
this should not be regulated at all
this is my view
but people certainly can argue the
process that you used is similar to
those that we use for conventional
biotechnology
but the fact is
we don't have anything left
we must display this i think it should
be easier okay i don't know actually
that's you should maybe i should say
first
then i my guess it should be easier
then your second question
um
can you remind me
acceptance
i think
that's probably very similar to uh
to the first situation we just need to
get a fact out this is really different
really different from the first
generation technology the television is
different
because there's nothing that really
knows nothing being involved in the
whole you know so why you want
ridiculous if less than ten dollars to
be resistant or tend to be higher or
higher quality
but
again
so we can ever
know
what public really reacted to that
technology
well that's that
to be honest here that's something uh
unexpected i i don't
expect uh
that kind of message will be conveyed
through last night i just want to make a
point that
it is a genome that make who we are
uh what the gorilla is
why gorilla is a gorilla
i i i i see a point okay i
our pet into that try avoid
necessarily left in that store okay
thank you for
the commentary i you know i have a slide
prepared for this
for this seminar then i'll take it out
um it's something
called the central dogma
dna makes rna makes protein
no eventually i'd like to take that
thing out
so i may consider to put back in
thank you
well the collection is this
um
so when you
start in course try to develop a new
apple varieties
you basically don't want
those
low seasonings in your breeding
population
so you want to
get rid of those
as early as possible to save some space
in the orchard so suddenly they'll be
reducing some of the
cost hopefully increase the breeding
efficiency because you can plan more
useful things in a limited area with
limited resources
so that's the point i
i i do not think
the eighty percent of poverty is now
have a high acid
now we
these are already developed
so what i'll talk about is for
getting the better varieties to get
sooner and quicker and better
thank you larry
um
my experience with master gardeners
are very positive
so
looks like they are very
more
more
they are very receptive
to
this kind of new information
suddenly my experience is also limited
okay
uh just based on what i uh the feedback
was the feedback that
that i get
now the experience with apple industries
a little bit different
so let me just show you uh let me just
tell you uh
one of the feedback that i get for the
two
uh basically for the two seminars that i
the two lectures that are given you know
winterfell schools for apple growers
um
so there are the scores like when
is the
worst four
is the best okay so basically four is
excellent
three
is good
and two is is fair and one is poor
so for the topic itself i got score 2.5
that's the audience
that's about the 400 audience the
feedback is probably more than 100.
so that's you well you know
well
okay the master gardener in the
gardening public do not
seem to be against
the idea of transgenic
apples or transgenic cabbages or
anything like that
i
i do not do not sense that do nothing
because when i give a talk i didn't i
didn't say
uh
the transgenics will be uh
will be used uh immediately suddenly we
need to go through the process i just
try to explain
the fact that neutral news technology
are there things that were getting
cleaner so it's more hopefully it'll be
more acceptable
to the to to them
no
it's uh
the
we look at their assets about
3.7
still within high acid range
in ph the
the ta is like
uh
t like like a 4
so uh
it's still we
within the bigger category of hyacinth
the
we also have the uh
the genotype
data using the market we developed fuji
is clearly the heterozygous
and the lucas
as a as an apple grower
i think we're living in one of the parts
of the world where people have
the greatest preference for tartar
varieties for
high acid or medium acid apples
and my sense is in most other parts of
the world except maybe western europe
people really prefer the lower acid end
of the range i guess my question is
what's the cut off you know what
we know that an apple when the furnace
gets below
seven pounds or something it won't taste
nearly but what's the cut off for the
city for example golden delicious
probably the most popular apple variety
in europe
now if you look at for ph and t at the
harvest it's way above the the border
that i said i said this ph 3.8 and the
ta 3.0 or 0.3.3 percent is way above the
range so way into the highest range what
i'm talking about the highest is not
really you can't even test it's
basically there's a relative term to
those
double
basically homologous law at the time
okay
let's all thank our speaker
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu